WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE OUGHT AT SUCH TIME
THAT I SEE THAT WE HAVE A QUORUM
IF YOU DON'T MIND I MIGHT STOP
US. TO ESTABLISH ROLL CALL ON
AND BEGIN.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO
THIS AFTERNOON SENATE BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE HEARING.
AS WE'VE COMPLETED THE HEARINGS
ASSOCIATE IT WITH THE JUNE
FIFTEENTH BUDGET PACKAGE WE NOW
BEGIN THE FOLLOW UP CLEAN UP
PHASE.
THIS IS THE FIRST PHASE OF THOSE
HEARING THAT ADDRESSES THE
FOLLOW UP ISSUE OF WILDFIRES.
TODAY WE'RE HEARING TWO BILLS A
B. ONE TEN AND A. B. ELEVEN
ELEVEN BUT THE BUDGET COMPONENTS
OF THE WILDFIRE PACKAGE.
THESE BILLS COMPLIMENT AB TEN
FIFTY FOUR WHICH WAS PASSED OFF
THE SENATE FLOOR MONDAY EVENING --
WE'RE CLEAR THAT SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WILL CONVENE HOPEFULLY
AS CLOSE TO ONE THIRTY AS
POSSIBLE.
WITH THAT WELCOME FINANCE WILL
GO HEAD HAVE YOU BEGIN ON A B..
ONE TEN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND I SHOULD ALSO INTRODUCED
WITH ME -- COLLEAGUE MATTHEW
THINKER WHO IS WHAT THE LAW FIRM
O'MELVENY MYERS WHO'S BEEN
ADVISING THE ADMINISTRATION ON
WILD FIRE RESPONSE MEASURES.
SO THE FIRST BILL BACK TO HANKER
YES MA'AM WELCOME MR HANKER
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SO THE FIRST BEFORE USE EIGHTY
ONE TEN THIS IS AN AMENDMENT TO
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
THAT WAS PASSED LAST MONTH THIS
BILL DOES TWO THINGS FIRST IT
IDENTIFIES EIGHTY ONE ELEVEN AS
A TRAILER BILL UNDER THE BUDGET
BILL.
AND THE SECOND ACTION THIS BILL
TAKES IS IT APPROPRIATE TO
MILLION DOLLARS ADDITIONAL TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THIS
IS FOR COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE RESPONSE MEASURES.
LEAVE MY VICE CHAIR IS ON HIS
WAY SO I'M JUST GOING TO LET US
PAUSE JUST A MOMENT.
BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE SURE HE
IS HERE AND ABLE.
TO HEAR THE PRESENTATION IF YOU
JUST GIVE US A SECOND
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
IT WAS [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THANK YOU AGAIN WE HAVE A
CONVENIENCE A SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND YOU WERE FINISHED ON A B.
ONE TEN THAT'S CORRECT OKAY
GREAT ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SENATOR NEAL
SAID.
PIPE DOWN ON KIND OF BOTH OF
THEM.
THE FIFTY WHAT TEN FIRST ALL
RIGHT WELL I'M I'M I'M.
CERTAINLY AND SUPPORT BUT THE
QUESTION IS.
THE SORT OF A MORE AMORPHOUS
WORK WORK WHAT'S IT GOING TO BE
USED FOR DO WE KNOW ANYTHING
SPECIFIC WHAT FINANCE WILL DO
WITH THE RESOURCES.
SEPARATE THESE RESOURCES WE BE
BASICALLY REALIZE THERE ARE
NUMBER OF MOVING PIECES AT
ACROSS THESE BILLS AND AS SMALL
AS A B. TEN FIFTY FOUR WHICH THE
CHAIR ALS MENTIONED.
SOWE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NIMBLE YOU
KNOW FIRST OF ALL THAT DIRECTOR
FINANCES A NUMBER OF
RESPONSIBILITIES RELATED TO
OVERSEEING YOU KNOW.
IN THE NEXT WEEK THE WILDFIRE
ALLOCATION METRIC BUT BEYOND
THAT EXAMINE THE BOOKS OF THE
WILDFIRE FUND ADMINISTRATOR BUT
MORE THAN THE SPECIFIC
RESPONSIBILITIES MAKING SURE
THAT ALL THESE PECES ARE
WORKING IN HARMONY THIS IS THAT
WE'RE STANDING UP THIS FUND IF
IT'S A B..
TEN FIFTY FOUR DOES PASS BOTH
HOUSES AND IS SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR THERE A LOT OF NEW
RESPONSIBILITIES AND SO THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTED TO KEEP.
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN RESERVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT FOR ANY
EVENTUALITY FOR THE COORDINATION
WE ARE READY AND ANY SPENDING OF
THOSE FUNDS WILL BE ACCOMPANIED
BY NOTIFICATION TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
OKAY.
I UNDERSTAND SO IT IS NOT SO
MUCH.
DOING THIS OR THAT BUT IT'S THE
COORDINATION OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES WITH ALL OF THE
AGENCIES AND WHATEVER THAT WILL
HAVE TO BE INVOLVED IN.
MAKING SURE THAT THE STATE
GOVERNMENT CAN BE NIMBLE AND
RESPONSE TO WHATEVER COMES UP
WITH HIM OKAY THANKS YES.
INTERNAL SIN ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM COLLEAGUES.
ANY QUESTIONS OR MAYBE ONE TENTH.
ALRIGHT HE'S SMILING.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE
IT OPEN BECAUSE WE STILL DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM.
OF FINANCES HE WOULD GO AHEAD
PLEASE IN PRESENT.
LET ME BACK UP.
ARE THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
A B..
ONE TEN ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
ALL RIGHT SEE NONE -- FINANCE A
B. ONE ELEVEN PLEASE. EIGHTY ONE
ELEVEN IS A TRAILER BILL AND I
SHOULD NOTE ON THIS POINT A
NUMBER OF THE POLICY CHANGES
RELATED TO WELFARE FIRES AND
CATASTROPHIC LOSS OUR RESPONSE.
OR AN AB TEN FIFTY FOUR THE
REASON THE ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVES.
THAT THERE SHOULD ALSO BE
TRAILER BILL IS SOME OF THAT
REORGANIZATION CHANGES THAT ARE
PART OF THE OVERALL BALLPARK
PACKAGE THE TRAILER BILL IS THE
MOWER APPROPRIATE VEHICLE.
IN ADDITION SOME OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS WITH REGARD TO
THE P. YOU SEE THOSE WERE
ORIGINALLY DISCUSSED AS PART OF
A CONFERENCE COMMITTEE THAT IS
PART OF THAT PROCESS -- WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE AGREED TO DEFER
DECISIONS ON THOSE ITEMS AND
TOLD THEY WERE CONSIDERED AS
PART OF THE OVERALL WILDFIRE
PACKAGE SO THAT'S WHY WE WANT TO
INCLUDE IN THIS VEHICLE -- AND
SO WITH REGARD TO THE ACTUAL
ITEMS OF THIS BILL ALTERNATE
OVER TEN MISTER HANKER WHO WILL
BRIEFLY DESCRIBE THEM.
THANK YOU MR HAGAR WELCOME THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN MITCHELL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
ADDRESS YOU TODAY I AM MATTHEW
THINKER FROM ON OF THE MYERS --
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES POSE A
THREAT TO CALIFORNIA'S PEOPLE
AND ITS ECONOMY.
THE LEGISLATION THAT YOU ARE
CONSIDERING TODAY TOGETHER WITH
A V. TEN FIFTY FOUR FACILITATES
WHAT IS NECESSARY FOR CALIFORNIA
TO ASSURE SAFE.
RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE ENERGY --
FAIR AND TIMELY COMPENSATION TO
VICTIMS OF THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FIRES AND CONTINUED
PROGRESS TOWARDS CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE GOALS.
WELL THE SAME TIME HOLDING UNTIL
HE'S ACCOUNTABLE FOR SAFETY.
THIS LEGISLATION ONLY BECOMES
EFFECTIVE IF AB TEN FIFTY FOUR
IS ALSO ENACTED.
SP ONE ELEVEN CREATES THREE
ENTITIES TO OVERSEE AND
IMPLEMENT MEASURES TO MATERIALLY
ADVANCE WILD FIRE SAFETY AND TO
ADMINISTER THE WILDFIRE FUND
CREATED BY AB.
TEN FIFTY FOUR THE CREATION OF
THESE ENTITIES WILL PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL OVERSIGHT OF THE
WILDFIRE FUND ADMINISTRATOR AND
WILL RESULT IN AN ENTITY
EXCLUSIVELY FOCUSED ON THE
SAFETY OF THE ELECTRICAL SECTOR.
ONE OF THE ENTITIES CREATED BY
THIS LEGISLATION IS THE
CALIFORNIA CATASTROPHE RESPONSE
COUNCIL.
THE COUNCIL APPOINTS AN OVERSEAS
WELFARE FUND ADMINISTRATOR AND
IS COMPRISED OF NINE MEMBERS.
THE MEMBERS OF THE COUNCIL OF
THE GOVERNOR.
THE TREASURER INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER.
THE SECRETARY OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY THREE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR MEMBER APPOINTED BY THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON RULES
AND YOU MEMBER APPOINTED BY THE
SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY.
THIS LEGISLATION ALSO REQUIRES
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
ESTABLISHED THE WELFARE SAFETY
DIVISION WITHIN THE COMMISSION
BY JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THE WELFARE STATE
DIVISION WILL RETAIN STAFF WITH
EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE AND
WHILE IF OUR SAFETY MITIGATION.
CLIMATE CHANGE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AND OTHER RELATED AREAS
AND OVERSEE ENFORCE ELECTRICAL
CORPORATION'S COMPLIANCE WITH
WELFARE SAFETY.
THIS DIVISION IS ADVISED BY WILD
FIRE SAFETY ADVISORY BOARD.
COMPRISED OF INDUSTRY EXPERTS
ACADEMICS AND OTHER INDIVIDUALS
WITH RELEVANT EXPERIENCE.
FUNNY THIS LEGISLATION ALSO
CREATES THE OFFICE OF THE ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY.
WITHIN THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY.
THE OFFICE WILL BE UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF A DIRECTOR.
NO LATER THAN JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ALL FUNCTIONS OF THE
WELFARE SAFETY DIVISION ARE TO
BE TRANSFERRED TO THE OFFICE OF
THE INNER OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY -- THANK
YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT [inaudible]
ANYTHING ELSE.
QUESTIONS MEMBERS HALF ON EIGHTY
ONE ELEVEN QUESTIONS.
SEE NONE IN THE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON EIGHTY ONE ELEVEN SEEING NONE
IF SERGEANTS COULD GIVE SOME OF
OUR COLLEAGUES.
A CALLER.
TO I'VE COUNTED MR UMBERG WE'RE
NOT THERE YET.
WE'RE NOT THERE YET -- AS SOO
AS WE'RE ABLE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM COLLEAGUES WILL BE ABLE
TO LOG INTO THE MOTION ON BOTH
BILLS.
AND WE'LL BE ABLE TO GO FOR IT
.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MITCHELL HERE WILSON.
WELL.
COVER EURO.
DOLLY.
HI -- TACO JOHN'S.
LABOR.
BUT WEIR.
I MEAN.
MORE LOCK.
PAN.
BROTH.
SKINNER STERN STONE NUMBER.
BY KASKI.
THE SECRETARY NOTICES THE
PRESENCE OF A QUORUM ALL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON A B..
ONE TEN THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
A B. ONE TEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS MITCHELL HI MITCHELL I
NILSSON.
I DOLLY HER TACO JOHN'S.
JONES NO LABOR LABOR HI MIKE
WEIR BUT WHERE I MONEY MONEY
NINE MORE LUCK PEN.
PEN ON A BROAD.
BRUSH I SKINNER STERN STONE
AMBER.
AMBER GUY LIKE HUSKY. NINE ONE
VOTE IS NINE ONE WE'RE GONNA
HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN ONLY TO TO
THE MOTION AB.
ONE ELEVEN IT'S BEEN MOVED MET
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL IF YOU WANT ELEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS MITCHELL HI
ALL I NELSON.
NELSON I BELL CAPOEIRA CAREER I
DOLLY HER TACO JOHN'S JONES NO
LABOR.
I BELIEVE I AM A WIRE BUT WIRE I
MONEY MONEY NINE MORE LUCK PAN.
PAN ON A ROTH ROTH ICE SKINNER
STERN STONE AMBER.
AMBER GUY WHY KASKI. NINE NINE
ONE OUR COLLEAGUES I'M GOING TO
HOLD THE ROLL OPEN.
UNTIL.
ONE TWENTY WHICH WILL ALLOW US
TO TRANSITION TO HEALTH
COMMITTEE ON TIME AT ONE THIRTY
AND SO WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN IN THIS COMMITTEE UNTIL.
ONE TWENTY SO BUDGET COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITHIN THE SOUND OF MY
VOICE PLEASE COME TO FORTY TWO
OR
THREE YEAH.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON A B. ONE TEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
AT ONE TEN BELL DOLLY HER TADO
MORLOCK SKINNER.
SKINNER ON EASTERN STONE WHY
KASKI WHY BECAUSE HE I PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON A B.
ONE ELEVEN WELL.
DOLLY HER DAUGHTER -- MORLOCK
SKINNER. FIVE SKINNER ONLINE
STERN STONE WHY BECAUSE HE
BECAUSE HE I ALL THE ITEMS UP
UNTIL ONE TWENTY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH
.
THE AREA WAS CLEAR IT WAS.
AND YOU SHOULD HAVE HEARD MY
OPENING REMARKS.
CHEST.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON A B. ONE TEN
IF YOU WON TEN BELL.
BILL I DOLLY HER TACO MORLOCK.
NO MORE LIKE NO [inaudible]
STERN STONE.
PHOTO OF TWELVE TO TWO THAT
MEASURE.
PASSED SINCE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
OF A B.. ONE ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE
ELEVEN BELL.
WELL I DAWALY FURTADO MORE LUCK.
HI MORE LIKE I STERN STONE.
THE VOTER THIRTEEN ONE THAT
MEASURE KERRY'S.
BUDGET COMMITTEE STANDS
ADJOURNED